el fiscal de Manhattan alvinbrá quería
que Donald Trump se entregara ayer mismo
de manera voluntaria pero su equipo el
equipo del expresidente dijo que era
imposible preparar el dispositivo de
seguridad en tan poco tiempo para que un
ex mandatario viaje de Florida a Nueva
York y luego se desplace aquí al bajo
Manhattan donde escucharía los cargos a
los que se enfrentan al final eso se
espera que ocurra Este martes y ya se ha
puesto en marcha toda la maquinaria de
seguridad hemos sabido que agentes del
servicio secreto estuvieron ayer en el
edificio de la Corte Penal siguiendo la
misma ruta que se espera que siga el
expresidente el próximo martes la
entrada la salida y asegurando
absolutamente todo según el Washington
post que dice que ha podido hablar con
un funcionario que se mantiene en el
anonimato cercano a la organización de
todo este dispositivo de seguridad se
van a necesitar decenas y decenas de
agentes para este desplazamiento y los
que no estén trabajando en la protección
del expresidente lo estarán las calles
velando porque no haya disturbios
también hemos sabido ha dicho el
servicio secreto ha dado a conocer que
está colaborando con agentes del FBI con
agentes de la policía de Nueva York con
agentes judiciales y también del Estado
para asegurarse que no hay ningún
problema en cuanto a seguridad en
principio según Fuentes cercanas al
expresidente Donald Trump el
expresidente vendría aquí viajaría aquí
el lunes por la noche dormirá en la
torre Trump y el martes se desplazará
hasta la Corte Penal aquí en el bajo
Manhattan para escuchar los cargos
seguramente salga ese mismo día porque
ninguno de estos cargos son violentos y
se espera o eso han dicho Fuentes
cercanas a su entorno que regrese
inmediatamente a su mansión en mara lago